welcome back to our sensor the clock is
ticking tonight on Israel's truths in
Gaza as many debate whether the
ceasefire should be made permanent
others argue that Israel must be allowed
to finish the job of eradicating Hamas
I'm now joined by Professor Alan B
through a war against the Jews how to
end Hamas barbarism and to debate him
the Palestinian American columnist Omar
badar well welcome to both of you um
Alan duris let me start with you uh
obviously your book very timely um you
know I've spoken a lot in the last
couple of months of the moral quandry I
feel about what is going on in Gaza I
have no moral quandry about what
happened on October 7th it was an
appalling terror attack I no quandry
about Israel's right and duty to defend
itself the quandry I have is whether
what is going on in Gaza is a
proportionate response given the massive
civilian death toll and given that so
many of them are children do you
understand that moral quandry and what
is your response to
it I fully understand it and I blame it
100% on Hamas which uses children as
human Shields it has a strategy it's
supporters call it the CNN strategy I'm
more direct I call it the dead baby
strategy what Hamas does is they kill as
many Israeli Jews as possible knowing
that Israel is going to have to respond
by going after their commanders their
tunnels and their rockets and so they
hide their commanders their tunnels and
their Rockets among babies and children
and and civilians and then when Israel
responds and tries to conduct a military
operation to prevent recurrence of these
uh barbarisms they bring the dead babies
in front of CNN and the New York Times
and the world of course sheds tears as
we all shed tears whenever we see a dead
baby and the World Turns against Israel
and then Hamas does it again and again
and again it's been doing it for 20
years with great success because the
media plays into it so there is a great
moral conjury but you know if I were to
Rob a bank and hold you uh Pierce as a
hostage and then start shooting on the
police in an attempt to stop me from
shooting or accidentally to shoot and
kill you under British law under
American law and Sharia law the
responsible person is not the person who
bullet killed the uh hostage it's the
hostage taker who's guilty of murder so
yes there's a moral conundrum but Hamas
is responsible for causing it okay uh
Omar bad I mean there's no doubt that
the scale of what Hamas did on October
the 7 was so overwhelming and horrendous
that Israel was always going to respond
like this Hamas knew that and my I guess
my question off the top to you is how
did that serve the Palestinian people
how does what Hamas did on the scale
that it did it knowing what the response
would be knowing thousands of innocent
Palestinians would die very quickly as a
consequence as well as people in Israel
how did that help the Palestinian
people I think there's a bigger question
here as far as context is concerned
which is that the single biggest organ
terrorist organization in all of
Palestine and Israel is known as the
Israeli government and the military wing
of this terrorist organization which is
orwellian named the Defense Forces of
Israel has engaged in massive war crimes
for decade after decade against
Palestinians engaging in the mass
killing of Palestinian civilians in land
theft in denial of water I mean just the
list of atrocities goes on and on and on
and if we want to just go by a timeline
a question might be why did the
terrorist government of Israel think it
can impose decade after decade of
occupation and Siege on Palestinians and
deny them any Prospect for a better
future and not think that there's going
to be a reaction of sorts so we have
this a little bit backwards we have this
arbitrary starting point of an attack by
Hamas which had it been confined to
military targets could have been uh con
you know ConEd as an act of legitimate
resistance but because it also included
attacks horrendous attacks on Israeli
civilians obviously these kinds of Acts
are indefensible
But ultimately we are talking about a
situation in which Israel is initiating
violence in which Israeli terrorism
dwarfs anything that Hamas has ever done
and we're watching that even expand to a
more monstrous scale now we're talking
about an apartheid government that is
engaging literally in the mass
starvation of a civilian population and
mass terrorism killing them by the tens
of thousands and the question is has it
gone too far I shudder to live in a
world where that's even a question of
course these kind of atrocities have to
come let me go back to Alan I mean this
is the problem Alam that think Israel
has in terms of global opinion here
especially from America which obviously
will play a key role um if as as the
report suggest once this uh temporary
pause is over they start barreling
through the south of Gaza it does beg
the question well what is going to
happen at the end of this is is the
military plan to Simply level the whole
of Gaza to the ground with perhaps 50 to
100 thousand or more uh civilians killed
in the process and is there any
guarantee of two things one that you
actually get rid of Hamas by doing that
because at the moment they can't say
I've already interviewed Israel
government spoken they can't tell you
how many Hamas terrorists they've
actually killed they don't know right
and it may be they've all disappeared um
but is that part of the military plan
and if it is what's the plan after this
what happens to all the displaced
Palestinian people they've got no homes
to go back to and how do you avoid the
obvious in my opinion consequence of
this which is just a massive increase in
radicalization from all those who've
seen their relatives blown to
Pieces well the plan Israel has had
since 1948 has been a two-state solution
it was offered to the Palestinians by
the UN they said no in 1967 again they
said no in 1990 in 2000 2001 2007 in
Gaza they ended the occupation and then
Hamas by a bloody military coup took
over over I haven't seen a single sign U
of protest calling for a two-state
solution Hamas is against the two-state
solution in its Charter it wants to
eliminate Israel completely from The
River To The Sea Palestine will be free
free of what free of Jews and then the
signs also say we want to clean the
world clean the world of Jews that's
what the Nazis said they called Jews
dirty and Vermin so the answer has to be
a two-state solution and and a peaceful
two-state solution but you can't have a
two-state solution
with Hamas because hamas's Charter is
against it maybe the Palestinian
Authority yes so I'm in favor of doing
what the United States did after the
second world war they totally destroyed
Nazism lots of people died lots of
civilians died but there wasn't an
increase in radicalism uh the German
people realized that getting rid of the
Nazis was the best thing that could
happen to the German people I'm hoping
that the Palestinian people will realize
that the same thing is true if Hamas is
ended the Palestinian people have a
great future Gaza can be Singapore in
the Mediterranean instead of a place
where terrorism thrives feating hungry
people Omar I mean do you believe
there's any future for Gaza that
involves Hamas at this
stage I think that's unavoidable I mean
honestly just the the onslaught of
untruths from Alan dtz I mean the only
person who has less regard for truth
than Donald Trump is perhaps dtz and
it's hard to know where to begin to
respond to all of this little there a
little let me just say yeah well I'm I'm
willing to back it up with actual facts
so here we go first of all question
human shield say are if let let me point
it all out to you here listen up first
of all on the question of human Shields
there is no question that Hamas hides in
civilian areas that's as a result of the
imbalance of power where Israel has
fighter jets that fly in the sky and a
massive milit a regular military force
but the issue of human Shields the
definition of human Shields is holding
civilians against their will and putting
them in front of you in combat to deter
enemy fire and the only party in this
conflict that has ever done that
documented by major human rights
organizations and a matter of fact is
actually the Israeli military using
Palestinian civilians including children
as human Shields that was a matter of
policy from 2000 until 2005 the Israeli
Supreme Court said that has to come to
an end in 2005 the Israeli military uh
protested that decision because it is
very useful for them to continue using
Palestinian civilians as human Shields
and even though the Israeli Supreme
Court banned it the Israeli military
continues to use it to this day there
have been numerous occasions documented
by Human Rights Watch by Amnesty
International and other organizations
and it tells you what this Sly is
ultimately about because if it is true
that Palestinian militants do not care
about the lives of Palestinian children
then what is the point of the Israeli
military using Palestinian children as
human Shields when they are in these
confrontations so that is simply a
lie don't use blame Palestinians for
their own let me get a final quick
response please ad a quick response
Adam if the Palestinian uh terrorists
put down their arms there would be peace
if Israel put down its arms there would
be genocide of the kind that occurred on
October 7th Israel cannot cannot put
down its arms because we know what Hamas
did on the 7th they would have done to
every Israeli if they had the ability to
do that and that's why isra
and that will benefit the world and that
will benefit the Palestinians and that
will lead to a two-state solution which
is not what my distinguished
opponent the two State solution argument
is nonsense throughout the entire
so-called peace process when Israel was
pretending to be engaged in a peace
process support for Palestinian violence
simply disappeared and in spite of that
Israeli land theft continued unabated
building more and more settlement
through the enti
gentle occurred right after the offer of
solution
gentle has no interest in allans fre we
run out of time I appreciate you both
joining me it's an important debate
we'll keep having it please both of you
come back again I appreciate
it